he promised
ethiopians an election that he will
almost certainly win
and as the votes are counted the prime
minister abi ahmed
prepares for a five-year term but in his
moment of triumph
he has suffered a blow in the restive
region of tigray
although it doesn't trouble his
supporters events on the ground right
now
are not over who knows stephen lift
could advance further we could advance
further you don't know i don't know i'm
trying to tell you
the story is large and complex it
doesn't start
here and here you're saying this
conflict isn't over
it doesn't even it didn't even start
the war into cry has been a brutal
affair
a battle for power waged between the
national government
and the region's former leaders the tplf
the ethiopian army took control of towns
and cities last november
but a week of fierce fighting has seen
them withdraw
to the delight of many who live there
[Applause]
and the government's declaration of a
ceasefire has been dismissed
our forces are in host pursuit
trying to finish them off on the road
but
until every square inch of stigma is
liberated from the enemy
when our offensive will continue
[Music]
that sounds like a serious setback for
dr abi
ahmed but down at the market in the
capital addis ababa
the traders said they had the prime
minister's back
why is that why is he your father
she's the most popular individual in the
country
the most popular well first of all
politics is everything in ethiopia
you know as i said we don't have
hollywood we don't have wall street we
don't have
nba you know all that but in ethiopia
the king is still everything you know
he's
and then he has an appeal of that you're
saying
abby ahmed is is the king he is
but his standing as a statesman has been
damaged by the eight months of conflict
into grind thousands of people have been
killed
and more than two million displaced and
the aid agencies have struggled to gain
access
to those affected five and a half
million people
in desperate need of support we believe
is is only a tip of the iceberg and
people have needed
help desperately so for the past eight
months now
and we as unicef within our mandate we
have been providing water and sanitation
the pressure is building on the man who
runs this country
with the u.s threatening sanctions
linked to the situation
integrai but one of ethiopia's
best-known citizens
has issued a warning i mean a lot of
pressure you know in this country
a lot of pressure i think you know the
western they have to be careful
they have to be careful former olympic
gold medalist
haley gabriel selassie says ethiopia is
bigger
and less stable than the international
community
thinks who is going to support you know
this fight between you know the brothers
between the brothers they are my
brothers
who is fighting in the bush
but again if you keep
just pushing you know this this way the
result will be very bad
the war in tigray has taken a turn and
the people of ethiopia
cannot escape it but the majority in
this country of 110 million
will trust their prime minister to
handle it john sparks sky news
in addis ababa